kampf gegen korona bayerns
ministerpräsident müller droht jetzt mit
einer ausgangssperre für das gesamte
bundesland hilfe durch die truppe die
bundeswehr bietet unterstützung an
so sollen soldaten not krankenhäuser
aufbauen und großrazzia gegen
staatsfeinde nach dem verbot einer
gruppe von reichs bürgern durchsuchte
die polizei wohnungen in zehn
bundesländern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am
donnerstag dem tag nach der
eindrücklichen rede der kanzlerin mit
ihrem appell die lage ernst zu nehmen
doch nicht alle halten sich an die
regeln zu hause zu bleiben und aufs
feiern zu verzichten
dabei sprechen die neuesten fall zahlen
eine eindeutige sprache
die amerikanische johns hopkins
universität aktualisiert mehrmals am tag
die zahlen für alle staaten weltweit
stand 18 uhr 30 sind danach in
deutschland 14 1481 menschen infiziert
etwa 28 prozent mehr als gestern
die zahl der toten stieg von 27 auf 43
länder wie italien und frankreich haben
bereits ausgangssperren verhängt damit
drohen mehrere ministerpräsidenten nun
auch für deutschland sollten die
menschen ihr verhalten nicht ändern
in bayern ist es schon soweit
ausgangssperre in der kleinstadt
mitterteich in der oberpfalz und im
landkreis wunsiedel irgendwann jeder
wird kontrolliert die ein und ausreise
ist nur noch in ausnahmefällen möglich
ausgangssperre in der kleinstadt
mitterteich im norden bayerns seit
gestern
grund sind die plötzlich relativ hohen
infektionszahlen unter den 7000
einwohnern die auftraten nach einem gut
besuchten bierfest nachdenklichkeit bei
den bewohnern als wort von 14 uhr an
starten gefäß und mitterteich und es
hätten es wahrscheinlich absagen müssen
heute weitere ausgangssperren wieder in
bayern betroffen zwei gemeinden im
landkreis wunsiedel
auch hier dürfen die menschen ihr haus
nur noch verlassen um zb einzukaufen zur
arbeit zu gehen oder zum arzt
und das könnte erst der anfang sein
der bayerische ministerpräsident erweckt
eine ausgangssperre für ganz bayern
deutliche worte in seiner
regierungserklärung vor dem bayerischen
landtag der nur in kleiner notbesetzung
zusammenkam um das infektionsrisiko zu
mindern
wenn sich so viele menschen nicht
freiwillig beschränken
dann bleibt am ende nur eine bayernweite
ausgangssperre als einziges instrument
und darauf zu reagieren das muss jeden
klasse widerspruch von der
niedersächsischen landesregierung
der innenminister hält diese ankündigung
für verfrüht
wir gehen einen etwas anderen weg wir
glauben dass es immer noch sinnvoll ist
an die vernunft zu appellieren und
gleichzeitig die maßnahmen die
angeordnet worden sind auch scharf zu
kontrollieren die einsicht der menschen
bleibt die große sorge der
verantwortlichen dennoch strengere
maßnahmen ergriffen werden hängt sehr
davon ab ob die bürger auch in ihrer
freizeit die bisherigen einschränkungen
einhalten die korona pandemie also eine
herausforderung und ein stresstest jetzt
zeigt sich wie vernünftig eine
gesellschaft agiert wie solidarisch und
rücksichtsvoll gegenüber älteren und
schwächeren jeder von uns muss plötzlich
liebgewonnene gewohnheiten aufgeben und
routinen überdenken beruflich wie privat
david sauer eine freie gesellschaft soll
sich einschränken
manche machen da nicht mit noch immer
stuttgart am nachmittag
allen warnungen zum trotz können viele
es nicht lassen tummeln sich auf plätzen
und in parks die polizei löst eine
versammlung der allzu sorglosen auf ich
glaube dass es wirklich egoismus gepaart
mit einer absoluten fantasielosigkeit
die können sich schlicht nicht
vorstellen dass sie auch eine
verantwortung haben nur wenn die
mehrheit der menschen das verinnerlicht
und befolgt werde die zahl der
neuinfektionen sinken sagen experten
aber viele sind verunsichert wie umgehen
mit einer situation die für alle völlig
neu ist ich habe einmal dies 81 und ich
will die nicht irgendwie in zwei wochen
oder in drei wochen irgendwo auf dem
krankenhausflur verdecken sie innerlich
gesagt
wenn ich jetzt im englischen garten
spazieren gehen sollte und mein sehe
dort entsprechende picknick
gruppenobmann die wir vor seine haus
weiß der mentalität was anderes ist es
ja nicht ob man sie da nicht ansprechen
sollten
bislang setzt die politik darauf dass
die bevölkerung freiwillig kooperiert
und sich vorbeugend verhält doch wie in
nachbarländern könnte es auch hier bald
mehr ausgangssperren geben wenn die
appelle bei manchen weiter verhallen die
korona krise belastet auch immer mehr
die wirtschaft die europäische
zentralbank stemmt sich nun mit einem
milliardenschweren notfallprogramm
dagegen konkret plant sie anleihen in
höhe von 750 milliarden euro zu kaufen
so sollen die euro-länder stabilisiert
werden dominic west meister hat die
einzelheiten
von hier aus kaufen sie nun noch viel
mehr staats- und unternehmensanleihen
die europäische zentralbank hat ein
notfallprogramm auf den weg gebracht
ezb-präsident hin lagarde schreibt dazu
auf twitter
außergewöhnliche zeiten erfordern
außergewöhnliches handeln es gibt für
unseren einsatz für den euro keine
grenzen wir sind entschlossen das volle
potenzial unserer möglichkeiten im
rahmen unseres mandats auszuschöpfen
länder wie zum beispiel italien müssen
in der korona krise mehr schulden machen
zb für den kauf von medizinischem gerät
am kapitalmarkt musste das land in den
letzten tagen dafür mehr geld zahlen
die zehnjährige staatsanleihe stand
gestern noch bei einem zins von 3
prozent jetzt kauft die ezb mehr
staatsanleihen der euro länder
die folge schuldenmachen wird billiger
im fall italiens gegen die zinsen für
staatsanleihen heute runter auf 1,65
prozent
die ezb ist ganz klar in vorleistung
getreten sie ist bereit zu intervenieren
um die finanzierungskosten für staaten
niedrig zu halten
aber die staaten müssen dann natürlich
aufschließen und die ezb nicht im regen
stehen lassen sie müssen klarstellen
dass sie die zukünftige höhere
verschuldung auch tragen können
zum ersten mal wollen die währungshüter
auch kurzfristige unternehmensanleihen
kaufen dafür sorgen dass firmen aufgrund
der krise nicht den
finanzierungsprobleme kommen
die ezb zeigt sich entschlossen alles
gegen die krise zu tun das ist ja eine
ziemlich einzigartige maßnahme valerie
haller an der frankfurter börse kann
dass die finanzmärkte beruhigen also
fürs erste sieht ganz danach aus wenn
man sich umhört breite zustimmung von
bazooka bahnbrechend massiv ist da die
rede die ezb macht ganz klar deutlich
sie will die wirtschaftlichen folgen
durch die korona krise abfedern gezielt
auch für kleinere unternehmen
sie will aber auch spekulanten die auf
die pleite von staaten wetten zeigen
probiert's erst gar nicht die ezb ist
stärker 117 milliarden euro pro monat
für anleihen das ist der ganz große
rundumschlag an der börse kam das paket
gut an wenn auch bei nervösem handel
beendet der dax den tag mit einem
soliden plus
auch die bundesregierung plant offenbar
hilfe für kleinstbetriebe und solo
selbständige das paket ist aber noch
nicht in trockenen tüchern
alle fahren in der krise auf sicht
sowohl die politik als auch die ezb
wollen notfalls nachlegen
und wahrscheinlich wird das auch nötig
sein danke für ihre erklärung valerie
auch dass eine konsequenz der korona
krise auf dem frankfurter flughafen wird
kommende woche eine landebahn zum
parkplatz für flugzeuge um funktioniert
wenn immer mehr maschinen bleiben am
boden
die lufthansa streicht 95 prozent ihrer
passagierflüge zehntausende mitarbeiter
sind in kurzarbeit wie der lufthansa
geht es praktisch allen airlines der
weltluftfahrt verband geht davon aus
dass viele fluggesellschaften ohne
staatliche hilfen in ihrer existenz
bedroht sind
die situation in der alten und
krankenpflege ist schon zu normalen
zeiten für alle beteiligten schwierig
jetzt während der pandemie wird sie zu
einem problem das kaum noch zu
bewältigen ist in deutschland gibt es
rund 4 millionen pflegebedürftige
ein teil von ihnen wird in einem der
11.700 pflegeheime versorgt zu anderen
kommt einer der mehr als 15.000
ambulanten pflegedienste damit patienten
auch künftig noch versorgt werden können
hat die regierung nur
erleichterungen zugesagt eva schiller
sie ist immer da die sorge dass das
corona virus hinein gelangt und so haben
sich pflegeheime wie hier in stuttgart
abgeschottet so gut es geht
auch wir dürfen aus sicherheitsgründen
nicht im gebäude filmen erreichen die
pflegedienstleiterin per videoanruf
[Musik]
schon vor der korona krise war die
personaldecke hauchdünn jetzt stricken
die heime im mangel notfallpläne und
fordern dass quarantäne regeln für
pflegekräfte großzügiger ausgelegt
werden
home office funktioniert in der pflege
nichts das heißt wir brauchen dringend
schnelltestverfahren erweitere
quarantäne
wenn wir die mitarbeiter nicht wieder
schnell in den dienst bekommen dann
fahren wir gegen die wand
gesundheitsminister sparen wir nun
pflegepersonal aus dem begutachtungs
dienst der krankenkassen in heimen
einsetzen und bürokratie abbauen
der pflege-tüv wird zunächst bis ende
september ausgesetzt
das heißt für die pflegeeinrichtung
einen deutlich reduzierten dokumentation
soffer ein anfang findet
pflegedienstleiterin goethe aber ob sie
den bewohnern auch auf dem höhepunkt der
krise noch gerecht werden können
da ist sie sich nicht zu sicher einem
bundeswehreinsatz im innern sind laut
grundgesetz sehr enge grenzen gesetzt
aber es gibt ausnahmen
und eine solche ist die korona krise
verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer will deshalb die
truppe in die pflicht nehmen helfen
können die soldaten bei der versorgung
von kranken oder notfalls auch beim
transport von waren klaus brodbeck
berichtet hier hilft die bundeswehr
bereits autobahn a4 nähe deutsch
polnische grenze soldaten versorgen
trucker mit nahrungsmitteln
die truppe unterstützt dort wo zivile
kräfte über engpässe klagen die
wirtschaft die polizeien das technische
hilfswerk und alle weiteren
institutionen an die grenzen kommen dann
werden wir selbstverständlich auch
helfen
ganz vorn dabei der sanitätsdienst der
truppe die selbst sieben bundeswehr
krankenhäuser betreibt verteilt über die
republik wie in allen kliniken sollen
auch hier die intensiv kapazitäten
verdoppelt werden im kampf gegen korona
mehr als 2300 reservisten haben sich
mittlerweile freiwillig per hotline
gemeldet um die reguläre truppe dabei zu
unterstützen mehr als 900 sind bereits
im einsatz sind also wirklich ich muss
sagen glücklich dass unsere reservisten
jetzt so da sind und sich melden um für
uns da zu sein
die bundeswehr leistet amtshilfe bei
logistik beschaffung versorgung aber
nicht als ersatz polizei trotz
entsprechender behauptungen im internet
gibt es gerüchte über allgemeine
ausgangssperren die die bundesliga
sozusagen auch entsprechend
kontrollieren soll
auf dessen einhaltung sie achten soll
das ist alles nicht der fall an der
autobahn rufen heute wieder die helfer
alle anderen auf zu hause zu bleiben
man kann es wohl nicht oft genug sagen
derweil spitzt sich die lage in italien
weiter zu das land kämpft mit
überlasteten kliniken und immer mehr
menschen sterben
seit heute zählt italien nach angaben
des zivilschutzes mehr todesfälle als
china in den vergangenen 48 stunden ist
die zahl sprunghaft von 2.503 auf 3405
gestiegen damit ist es nun das land mit
den meisten todesfällen durch das corona
virus italien ein land am limit erlebt
annette hilsenbeck militärlaster auf dem
weg zum krematorium von bergamo sie
holen die särge mit denen ab die den
corona virus zum opfer gefallen sind
bringen sie in benachbarte provinzen so
viele sind hier in den letzten tagen
gestorben die kapazitäten reichen nicht
aus die zahlen sind unfassbar
man hat ausgerechnet das was wir sonst
in sechs monaten haben jetzt in zehn
tagen passiert ist
die krankenhäuser in der lombardei im
norden italiens sind überfüllt mit
patienten an beatmungsgeräten und die
zahl der neu infizierten steigt indes
noch immer das medizinische personal
arbeitszeit wochen am limit jetzt erneut
der hilferuf eines arztes der nicht mehr
weiter weiß
wir suchen verzweifelt krankenschwestern
und ärzte dazu beatmungsgeräte und
schutzkleidung die ausgangssperre in
italien wird wohl wegen der immer noch
katastrophalen zahlen verlängert werden
das deutete premierminister konnte
gestern an die italiener nehmen es
bisher ergeben hin in den supermarkt
dürfen nur wenige kunden dafür gilt
abstand halten
im supermarkt sind alle gelassen es gibt
ja den sicherheitsabstand den alle
einhalten
hoffen wir dass es was nützt und die
versorgung weiterhin gesichert ist so
ist es ja schon traurig aber dann würde
es noch schwerer
es ist ein trauriger vorgang die haben
corona virus verstorbenen werden
außerhalb ihrer heimatstadt beigesetzt
und die die um sie trauern können nicht
dabei sein
anders die situation in china erstmals
seit dem ausbruch des corona wäre es
wurden keine neuinfektionen gemeldet
auch nicht in der besonders betroffenen
stadt wuchern
ob aber die offizielle statistik die
wahre lage widerspiegelt ist unklar
hatte doch china mehrfach die zählweise
bei den infektionen geändert und damit
immer wieder für verwirrung gesorgt
unfälle
wie die ankunft eines mächtigen
regierungschefs inszeniert in den
sozialen medien die staatspropaganda die
heimkehr der ärzte aus der krisenregion
huber
die partei hat den sieg über das virus
beschlossen und liefert die passenden
zahlen dazu keine inländischen corona
infektionen mehr das volk feiert die
ärzte und pfleger als helden
sie haben die gesundheit der menschen in
wohin mit ihrem eigenen leben verteidigt
wir sind ihnen aus vollem herzen dankbar
china schmeißt den wirtschaftsmotor an
bilder aus der provinz hubei in der auch
woran liegt sie war am schlimmsten vom
virus betroffen
gerade die autoindustrie ist hier groß
seit einigen tagen wird in den fabriken
die produktion wieder hochgefahren
aber unser kontakt in der stadt wo hand
schickt uns diese handyaufnahmen die
strengen ausgangssperren gelten weiter
für alle die die nicht dringend in den
fabriken gebraucht werden
ich habe das gefühl dass in den letzten
paar tagen die behörden noch strenger
geworden sind sie möchten wohl nicht
dass am ende der krise noch etwas
passiert die gefahr für die chinesen
kommt jetzt aus dem ausland sie haben
angst dass mit den einreisenden das
virus mit einreist massive
sicherheitsmaßnahmen am flughafen jeder
der nach peking kommt muss für zwei
wochen in quarantäne zurück nach
deutschland keiner darf mehr rein und
nun müssen auch alle raus in schleswig
holstein und mecklenburg vorpommern gilt
ein komplettes touristen verbot
um die ausbreitung des corona virus zu
bremsen die letzten urlauber müssen noch
heute auch die insel verlassen die hier
auf sylt zurückbleiben einsame
küstenstrände menschenleere
einkaufsstraßen und verlassene
hotelbetten
auch die ostseeinsel usedom macht die
schotten dicht und das für unbestimmte
zeit auch heute senden wir wieder ein
zdf spezial zur krone epidemie direkt
nach dieser 19 uhr heute sendung
jederzeit auf dem laufenden sind sie mit
unserem live blog auf heute de und in
der heute app immer mehr menschen
beziehen elterngeld laut statistischem
bundesamt waren es im vergangenen jahr
rund 1,9 millionen 2 prozent mehr als im
jahr davor
bei den männern waren es sogar 5,3
prozent mehr
mit durchschnittlich 11,7 monate bleiben
die mütter weiterhin deutlich länger zu
hause als die väter hier sind es knapp
drei monate bundesinnenminister seehofer
hat erstmals eine gruppe der sogenannten
reichs bürger verboten
in zehn bundesländern gab es razzien bei
21 führenden vereinsmitgliedern in wird
rassismus und antisemitismus vorgeworfen
die sogenannten reichs bürger lehnen den
deutschen staat in seiner bestehenden
form ab und erkennen dessen gesetze und
behörden nicht an minuten leinhos
die ermittler kommen im morgengrauen sie
durchsuchen diese villa im süden berlins
im bezirk lichterfelde
insgesamt sind 400 beamte bundesweit im
einsatz
das verbot der gruppierung begründet der
minister mit ihrer
verfassungsfeindlichen haltung wir haben
es mit einer vereinigung zu tun die
rassistische und antisemitische
schriften verbreitet und damit unsere
freiheitliche gesellschaft systematisch
vergiftet die polizei aktion richtet
sich gegen mitglieder des vereins
geeinte deutsche völker und stämme den
der verfassungsschutz der reichs bürger
szene zurechnet sie lehnen den deutschen
staat ab viele mitglieder gelten als
waffen auf ihn in nordrhein westfalen
bei zeitgleichen razzien wie hier in
gummersbach finden die ermittler
schusswaffen und propagandamaterial ein
vorwurf gegen mitglieder der gruppierung
verbale nötigung da werden drohschreiben
an amtsträger geschrieben
pseudo haftbefehle erstellt und
strafzahlungen gefordert eingefordert
das alles soll der einschüchterung
dienen das verbot der gruppierung nennt
bundesjustizministerin lamprecht einen
wichtigen schlag die reichs bürger szene
sei groß und verfügen über viel zu viele
waffen
schon mehrfach wurden wohnungen so
genannte reichs bürger durchsucht
bundesweit haben sie laut
sicherheitsbehörden rund 19.000
mitglieder darunter 950
rechtsextremisten
fast alle großen opern und konzerthäuser
dieser welt sind geschlossen die
aufführungen abgesagt verzichten muss
auf musikalische unterhaltung trotzdem
keiner
wenige klicks reichen und die wiener
staatsoper kommt in jedes wohnzimmer
live oder aus dem archiv kostenlos für
alle auch die bayerische staatsoper hat
einen digitalen konzertsaal eröffnet
[Musik]
schöne aktion zum wetter
das wird im norden kühl und trüb im
süden warm und gewittrig zu den
einzelheiten gleich gunther tiersch so
viel für den moment marietta slomka und
das heute journal heute gegen 22 uhr
schön dass sie dabei waren morgen wird
sie an dieser stelle barbara hahlweg
informieren ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
guten abend tschüss
[Musik]
meine liebe zuschauer die insektenhotels
sind gut besucht und das vertonen ja
auch bei uns jetzt kühle tage die
wetterlage seit gestern hat sich kaum
verändert im norden immer noch die
dicken wolken auch über der nordsee aber
jetzt drängt diese wolkenfront in die
mitte deutschlands und mit ihr die
deutlich kühlere luft im süden dagegen
haben wir schwül warme luft und das
bedeutet morgen nachmittag dann dort
schauer und gewitter heute nacht
jedenfalls erst einmal nur weiterhin ein
trübes wetter im norden immer wieder
sprühregen im norddeutschen tiefland
sonst klarer himmel im süden ein paar
nebelfelder
und nur ganz vereinzelt gibt es noch mal
leichten frost vor allen dingen hier
südlich der donau
morgen haben wir dann temperatur extreme
oder extreme unterschiede
das heißt in norddeutschland sind es nur
noch sieben bis elf grad aber in der
südhälfte 17 bis 21 grad und der
vormittag der wird eben im süden noch
mal richtig sonnig im norden bleibt es
trüb immer wieder regnet und in
schleswig-holstein lockert schon ein
bisschen auf das setzt sich nachmittags
an den küsten ford mit diesem mäßigen
nord bis nordostwind und im süden wird
es auch bewirkt da tauchen dann schauer
und gewitter auf die vom schwarzwald
langsam weiter nach osten ziehen werden
ja es wird dann noch ein bisschen kühler
werden am samstag überall mit schnee-
und regenfällen im süden dann ab sonntag
wird es sonnig auch am anfang der
nächsten woche und nachts gibt es eben
auch leichten frost
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut